[Musik]
und in diesem sinne heiße ich euch recht
herzlich willkommen auf einem kanal
ich zeige euch jetzt wieder diese
leckeren kaffee kekse machen können die
eignen sich ideal zum verschenken oder
zum selber verlassen
für unseren text benötigen wie es bei
160 gramm mehl 1 1 2 espresso 110 gramm
puderzucker 130 gramm butter 50 g
speisestärke ein teelöffel backpulver
und 30 gramm bacau
zuallererst nämlich um eine schüssel
geben da die butter das all und dem
puderzucker hinein und verknüpfe das
einmal mit den händen
wenn sich das einigermaßen verbunden hat
gebe ich bei es für espresso dazu
[Musik]
dann gebe ich die speisestärke dazu
danach kommen backpulver und hinein und
anschließend auch das mehl
[Musik]
nach circa fünf minuten erhalten wir
dann einen kompakten und festen teig
den um wirklich mit frischhaltefolie
damit der menschen ausdruck klappt jetzt
lege ich mir schon mal meinen backblech
mit backpapier zurecht und stechen mir
dann zu meinem zeigt immer kleine kugeln
ab
die kugeln werden dann oval geformt und
auf dem backblech platziert
nachdem dann alle kaffeebohnen geformt
bin ich habe übrigens frei in halblech
heraus bekommen können wir mit dem
zahnstocher einmal in der mitte
durchstechen so dass wir da eine gerade
linie rein bekommen noch einfacher und
schneller ist es aber wenn sie mit einem
messer rhein steht jetzt werden die
kaffeebohnen oder 180 grad ober und
unterhitze für acht minuten gebacken und
hier seht ihr die fertig gebackenen
kaffee kekse
ich kann euch nur sagen dass wir super
lecker schmecken und ein hauch von
kaffee note haben und eingepackt und
luftdicht verpackt halten die sich zirka
vier bis fünf wochen
falls euch das video gefallen hat freue
ich mich über einen daumen hoch und ein
abo bis zum nächsten mal auf die spitze